[تصفيق]
الحياه في غزه بعد خمسه ايام على القصف
العسكري الاسرائيلي تنبض مجددا يا رب الله
يصبرنا ليس بسهوله فالناس يسعون الى تغيير
ملامح الشوارع والمباني
لكن الاصعب لملمه الجراح بعد عشرات
الشهداء والمصابين والدمار الكبير
ومثل اخرين يكافح ابو وائل لترتيب ماوى
لاسرته يعني مش هذا هذا قنبله نوويه هذا
بيت يعني طالع للسكن انا كل مره في اولادي
كلهم اللي امبارح طلعوا بره البيت الان
هيك انت خشيت واتفرجت في البيت
مفتحة
عشر ايام المرابط منذ ساعات الصباح بدا
العمل في كل اتجاه لاعاده تاهيل هذه
الاحياء والبنى التحتيه فيها ليتمكن
سكانها من العوده اليها وتقوم ايضا
الكوادر لدينا ايضا بكل ما لديها من طاقه
من معدات ومن فنيين ام بصيانه شبكات
الكهرباء التامين الكهربائي للمواطنين وكل
الكوادر تعمل بجميع طاقاتها لذلك الامر
دبت الحركه في الشوارع وفتحت الاسواق
وباستثناء المؤسسات التعليميه استانف
العمل في جميع المؤسسات الرسميه فعلا يعود
هدول من خلينا نعيش بدونش يخلونا نعيش
بدونش
سينما اكيان فلسطين بدهم ايانا كل يوم
والثاني حرب وحرب حرب حرب حرب
لا يعرف سكان الاحياء المتضرره مدى
انتظارهم لاصلاح ما دمره العدوان
الاسرائيلي لكن ليس امامهم سوى الانتظار
وشوان بدي اروح
في الليل بروح عند قرايب بنام الصبح بضطر
اجي انا واولادي هنا زي ما انتشفت الدار
والشارع واحد مين بده يصلح لنا
كم حرب اجت ما شفناش منهم حاجه اذا ستبقى
اسره ابو وائل في منزلها المتضرر بعد
انتهاء التصعيد العسكري الاسرائيلي ليس
لديها ولا لسكان قطاع غزه اي ضمانات بعدم
التعرض للقصف مره اخرى اوقف اطلاق النار
لكن الناس في غزه يستانفون حياتهم تحت
الحصار نفسه هبه كيلا الجزيره من مدينه
غزه